assalamu aleikum wa rahmatullah wa
barakato we have come here to reading to
address a very serious issue and one
which concerns both Muslim communities
and non-muslim communities the question
is when the government gives money to
Muslim organizations for
counterterrorism what do these Muslim
organizations do today we're going to
investigate the case of the Salafi
publications and their offshoots and
associates a group of people who have a
record of accepting money from prevent
and other counter extremism agencies
with the pretense of being able to
counter all yeah D radicalize if you
like Muslim people the question is is
that really what they're doing with the
money
is it advisable for taxpayers money to
go on such services and such activities
when in fact there can be evidences and
there are allegations of the money being
this approach misappropriated today
we're going to speak to one of the
affected parties in reading in a famous
case where there is compelling evidence
for the allegation of a misappropriation
of funds we will talk about with our key
witness some of the real problems
pertaining to how these organizations
make the initial bid to D radicalize
Muslim communities take money and we
don't see the fruits of such d
radicalization at all salam alikum
warahmatu liar what I care - I'm here in
reading with that we'll have saw one of
the main witnesses for this case this
case which of misappropriation of wealth
and and basically this this case is
about sixteen and a half thousand pounds
I have been taken from counsel money and
and actually misappropriated completely
so what I'm gonna be asking Bahasa today
is about the evidence for that so alikum
how you have bahasa I'm going to put
over half so social media details in my
description box so you can see a list of
all documents that will be referred to
today
in on his Twitter and also I'll be
making a specific reference to send
documents and putting those specific
documents in the description box as well
so my first question is 16 and a half
thousand pounds you allege has been
taken i misappropriated by this this
community or these individuals that take
I've taken it what is your evidence for
that okay our evidence is that we have a
witness who was involved in the whole
project yeah brother name is e Samantha
and he first informed us that these
brothers meaning the problems were run
in the Masjid that was called ready
Islamic information center yes that they
applied for funding under the prevent
scheme and they were awarded the funding
our first will be her this will kind of
surprised when I was shocked actually to
find that those brothers had received is
funny because I was not aware of this
hmm so I party so look you need to prove
this so you need to bring the evidences
so he searches are come ahead into it he
went to the counter the following day
and I went with him so we both went to
the council and ISA obtained the
documents from the cancer so what you
obtained was that you obtained a big
document which is an application which
the brothers put forward requesting the
funding and we received the contract on
the cancer but you and you have those
documents yes of course I'll put them in
yeah you can add them to your link there
on my Twitter account right so the
second document was a contract between
them and a council staying where they
will spend the money and XYZ and then
the end of the end of the year report
which they produced in that report is
where they justify where this money went
and that's going to be kind of the main
evidence the end of the year
or because in that report they've lied
in there and claimed that they've paid
people and stuff which they hadn't right
so let's get this clear the council gave
sixteen and a half thousand pounds on
prevent for anti-terrorism related
activities to these to these individuals
who claim to be Salafi etc and you're
saying that the money that was given was
not used for those anti-extremism
activities in effect was misappropriated
completely well from what we know is
that they were awarded sixteen and a
half thousand pounds yes and in the end
of the year port where they've
justifying where the money went
they claimed to have paid witnesses we
stay had a paid and I'll give you a few
examples all right so I've got the same
document here yeah this is my witness
report which of the you can add to your
economic documents and in the in the end
of the year they've mentioned this Brava
called AB Dupree Abu Sufian
of the pre McDowell okay who is coming
in every week to do one of the main
speakers yes
they claim to take him and we have a
witness statement from him saying that
he did receive any funds from them right
and his fuel and other expenses and the
food and everything else was covered by
the brothers right maybe by myself yep
another example is the you paid for that
yourself yeah mainly yeah with the main
contributor towards these events okay
another point to mention is in the end
of the year report they mentioned that
they had a female only event which was
copied delivered by a qualified without
cupping what's that got to do with
anti-terrorism exactly now a funny thing
about it is the actual female copper was
the wife of one of the men towards Abdul
Allah Allah money exactly yeah dr. Abdul
need enough money mm-hmm and when I
approached him or text him and I asked
him did your wife get paid for this
event he
say no and you've got that detail you've
got evidence I may have I'm gonna have
to look for it yeah it's well known I
believe it's in one of the recordings
yes it's on your throat aha
but anyway it's a well known fact so of
question of did a lot of money regarding
this and said did your wife get paid by
the brothers for this event and he said
no no also another example is that a
claim said that in December 2010 they
had a mini conference which they did in
that conference both of the men to ask
one of them abou a teacher of the white
and Abu hockey Bilal Davis both came
from reading and did that conference in
the Birmingham meeting in question name
this myself and Issa and Allah and we
have Abdul Latif was also present and
they are witness to that they were
surprised that they didn't know that
would be useful right and so they said
they denied that they got any payment
they received any fundings and also they
were surprised and they grilled child in
the meeting because they were unaware
and this amusing that you had that we
had in 2016 mmm-hmm and the details in
the meeting is on my Twitter account
anybody another thing is another thing
they mentioned was the beginner Arabic
course
now this Arabic quote did take place for
six weeks
I believe there's only for an hour a
week okay what were the instructors
painters I don't know what hour because
the DVD fighting terrorism anyway right
and one of the main issues with this is
that it was not in the original
application yes so in the original in
the bid in the initial the big document
it states that 9,000 pounds will be paid
for two part-time workers or part-time
workers yes I think yes it says two
part-time yeah mini-conference of 1500
pounds which were they were awarded for
and a two thousand pound for admin and
management and printing and publication
of literature 1,500
was there any literature that was
produced nothing at all so leaflets in
terms of reduced by the brothers at all
well this is one of the main problems we
have is that the brothers that claim to
have what it says also here for an into
1,000 pounds for Internet webpage
Internet web page was WOW at that time
okay so this is what led us to believe
that those brothers stole the funds
because none of these things that
mention here more time so getting back
mm-hmm so we mentioned about the contact
between them and the council mmm yes
well out of the whole event some things
did take place yes but those activities
that they mentioned they paid for those
speakers when operator
yeah we're not paid mm-hmm and most of
the expenses were covered by either
myself and you have some evidence for
this if anyone were to ask you like you
know yes yeah and here's a question do
they have evidence of the contrary what
is what we asked them you be my asking
them for almost three years now right
what we like for them to do is bring us
evidence of proof or receipts that
updated to the son hated not updated
back at that time yep they're going back
in 2009 and 10 11
I believe they put the application in
2009 but the one I would the money
around 2010 2010 or 2011 that was the
time they were awarded the money and at
that time it is fired off at the center
but it became a much it mm-hmm
in fact the actual contract that decided
accounts or was in August and it became
a must year the few must be for that
mm-hmm alright so okay can you explain
what kind of effect this has had on the
community because here what we know from
the discussions that we've had is that
you you know this side of making
accusations about you guys and after
that they started doing a boycott on you
guys so what is this what's happened in
the community after after these kind of
allegations were made with the evidence
has provided that we've just seen here
which are quite compelling to be
what happened after that in terms of
them yeah the first thing we did is when
we tried to contact the Provost private
addressed mm-hmm and tried to talk to
them and say look he says came to this
accusation but he's bought evidences yes
we've seen these documents and Neely's
documents the end the report is full of
lights clear lies all these you know
things that you claimed to have done
what actual actual mustered up teasers
and I'll give you a few examples not one
of them yes I mentioned was that they
beforehand twice yes no I thought about
the children's class the teacher himself
was s Amanda I need confirm he didn't
get paid from any funding and rather the
parents have paid for with we met you
Saturday night yeah he's confirmed that
three brothers yeah he's also confirmed
that the parents were paying for that we
are witness statement from the parents
that said that so so the parents are
paying for it the government thinks that
they're paying for it and the government
thinks that they're paying for it to
fight extremism no but this is this
shows you I mean it's not even in the
initial bid is it an initial bid these
things that they mentioned in the
end-of-year report are not in the
initial bid him and things like the
weekly classes obviously has confirmed
that he didn't get paid for that
the female couple do confirm double lead
up the lilac money and he denies it I'm
ready to take my body with him well now
you wanna do you know the mini
conference was done and Abu Hakim and a
belief a teacher in the conference both
of them will be held but how do you love
people witnesses
well we've met some of your witnesses
today haven't we do a bit too camera shy
but we're at least two of them today and
we've been on the phone to to numerous
others and it does seem like there is
corroborating witness testimony to
everything you give your circles so
initially we wanted to you know
house if you like and then we ask the
problems that we requested that they
give us an explanation of what took
place yes and show us the proof so under
what had religious involvement and pull
Davis when they found out about this
what was their reaction
well we contacted them ourselves to have
a meeting and it was agreed and we went
to this meeting and at that meeting
those both of a hockey Minerva Katya
were judging in the affair hmm we kind
of surprised we didn't expect that we
just thought it was gonna be meeting he
said the evidence if we don't they're
gonna question both brothers an XY said
what took place in the meeting is a
statement that we put together so if you
relate to that state when they stare on
Twitter mm-hm and the details but uh in
that meeting it was judged by our hockey
that there was miss his probation of
funds hmm and that he was suggesting for
sure and you have evidence where we have
the witness statements you yes sir
problems that were present in the
meeting I know so we have recording
someone you do have that CCTV footage
but anyway our question it's quite safe
already
where did the money go that's right what
did you do with the money that's what he
comes out to so what we went to
Birmingham hmm which as I said I'm a
hockey man Hypatia well Hakim judged
that they would miss preparation of
France and that we suggested a shy to be
stepped down from the shore
no not sure there's the one who is very
free with the main guy yeah the one
who's doing this mustn't miss
appropriate shots right in three four
years down the line three four years
down the line if you go to did for blood
you still see shy holding the bucket
you'll still see you'll know if you're
going up but you might maybe upset maybe
after this video
[Laughter]
I'll also send you a lot to send you an
audio clip yes one of the members that
was in the meeting in Birmingham in the
name of Adam Junaid hmm and you will
hear originated stating even in a secret
recording where he states that it's not
from hikmah for shy to be holding the
bucket oh yes I'm shy be a Steve any
third thing then what's the problem with
him holding the bucket mmm and so what
you're saying is that there was this
misappropriation of funds and because of
the gang mentality related to this this
this gang you know
Abraha DJ and I will bill out Paul
Phillips they tried to cover it all up
and the normally did they cover it up
but they tried to attack you for coming
out with it what happened so what
happened in the beginning was we went to
them and they judged it so we left it at
that we thought you know we just moved
forward the dour and Hum Dil uh you know
we wanted the assumption that you know
things were okay but then we came back
to ready and the brothers in ready
were attacking us on the member and
accusing of so this is all economic then
I mean this is I mean we thought I'm in
Ghana below we are to think that a lot
of these things that all these problems
are happening with tip dia and labeling
and things like that are actually
related to the religion but what's being
said here seems to know it seems to be
the case that they're using religion as
an ammunition like to to further their
own economic project that's the
allegation allegation but anyway getting
back to what you say after that you know
they start attacking us and you know I
was a DJ himself came to Redmond did a
lecture I mean that lecture he changed
the brothers of being infiltrated
infiltrators so this is why we decided
in January to go public and to defend
our honor the only reason what went
public was to defend her honor in this
because we based our accusation based
upon evidence so now it's on them to
prove they have them in the bulletin
core since you've made the allegations
and you've made the put the evidences
forward they have to they have to
produce the the receipts as you've
mentioned and and I won't ask a final
question when they've come to reading
what was the difference in doubt between
before and after they've come and they
had their they put their hand into into
the affairs of the reading community
will do community I think in general
there wasn't any issue with the brothers
the brothers were United together is one
individual in particular that came and
he had you know like you know this is
the one that kind of you know what'll be
you know yeah this that we did in
an encounter harshness with him and
that's when we noticed that that will
begin to change and they started making
a hot yet of a few which is boy calm
evidence it so when we questioned them
this is where they kind of you know turn
the guns if you like mm-hmm and we've
we've got information that suggests I
mean obviously we can't go into too much
detail but they've got many companies
either come limited companies or
charities now I get hundreds of
thousands of pounds like you know
selected publications charity and 2014
which is not far away from this time
we've got a million pounds in in funds I
mean we can't make any allegations on a
legal level but is it safe to assume
that a lot of that money is coming from
prevent and should prevent and the
government and the council in your
opinion would you advise them to be more
cautious as to how and why they would
give money to to people that have a
track record of this that's the question
the question is when you look into the
overriding affair yes one thing I picked
up a notice that the actual initial
application that was given to the
council in there's mention that that the
reading organization is affiliated with
the Birmingham organization which was
inner city guidance yes which is Paul
Davis is an organization that is
Hakeem's
[Music]
so can you make that point again so what
which one is associated with which so in
the documentation in the initial bit
which is the application that portal to
the console yeah it mentions that they
mentioned that there worked with or
affiliated with in Assateague Island
City guidance which is pool Davis's
organization which has been dissolved by
the way yeah no accounts no conscious
yeah no counts because it changed into a
charity I've looked in seas right and
even on both on that there's no accounts
yeah but we know what we know from what
you're saying that there was money
pumped into that as well why the kapre
yes why this big cover-up and why try to
you know cover this whole thing up
questions I'm not gonna accuse them yeah
we can't already it's great cop just
click up in ask Lake up yeah you know we
could use the evidences now they have to
produce the receipts receipts and show
us where these money is gone so there's
another allegation that the reading
islamic information center have been
using my GG bells charity registration
number to claim tax relief which is
actually a cable which is actually an
allegation of council tax fraud yes I
did some research
only when the novel wanted to sell the
building so maybe next occasion and in
the business I did a little research and
code up the council and believe the link
is you can add the link of the audio and
I'm questioning the council regarding
this and they told me that the bill is
registered under mark is more artificial
my surprise I was quite shocked so I
went to go visit the brothers in Slough
and arranged to see abdula dalla Mandy
and I approached him and I question him
regarding this and he was shocked and
amazed at the time and you'll hear from
the secret recording where the
profitable concern with this and
I said to them look you know these
individuals are using your charm status
you know is there some food that they've
done while you implicate in this or you
know did you give him permission they
denied it the night they gave permission
to him today but later on down the line
a month later once I sent him the
evidences these are all diamo Twitter
account where of develop money very
upset and he claims that he did get them
permission and he claims I remember
again this is a serious fault
hmm and these individuals the likes of
the Lahani al-fatihah Albuquerque one
bomb in the tower is a big question mark
on a dollar and they trustworthiness
absolutely would you say that there has
been a sectarianism his be as is
referred to in Arabic in the treatment
of Muslims generally Sunni Muslims that
claim to even be Salafi you know they
came to be Salafi and then now they're
being boycotted they're being attacked
because they're coming up with these
evidences in writing and say look we've
paid for these things and all of the
things are happening it and now you've
boycotted us and their taxes have you
experienced any of that yourself well
this is was amazed as brothers you have
these individuals who claim to be upon
scent of here and they claim to be
people of evidence and claim to be
people of chief and Hawkins on so and we
were made for lighting inmates we get
bubbles duck callers and they say I feel
you know we're hearing this and that and
what's our simple mind about the
brothers and when you question them you
said have you gone for evidence II know
have you looked at them you know you see
the voice notes have you seen the amount
of evidence
yes abide it and you find no so it's
like how did you come to that conclusion
right right how can you judge that the
brothers on line we faced everything
upon evidences so yes yes definitely a
hundred percent it seems to be a his
beer so in other words you're saying
that they think they're immune to
criticism there'll be a cover anything
happens within the Muslim community and
they're involved they'll always vouch
for their own you know blatant
double standards and everything else it
amazes me well thy amazes me and the
situation already iliza sad situation
because we've had the boycotting of
Salafi prophets without justification
and evidence is attacking Salafi purpose
from the member warning against Salafi
brothers not returning the salam to the
brothers and the general folk so to
conclude with the recent scandal with
hassan antenor mandala where they've
been leading double lives it's led the
Muslim community to investigate who else
is doing leading a double life if you're
like who else is taking money saying
that they're gonna do one thing with
that money and they're doing something
completely different with it who else is
scamming not only the Muslim community
but the non-muslim community and even
the government with money and our
investigations lead us to these kinds of
places places where historic cases cold
cases even have been remade we unearth
them if you like and lots of evidences
have been brought forward now the ball
is in the core of those individuals and
Salafi publications as we mentioned in
organisation in 2014 alone which got 1
million pounds of charity funding now we
want to understand where they got that
money from in the first place because
their social media accounts don't don't
suggest that they can get that kind of
money from general fund raising or
Masjid fundraising but if we were to
assume that that was from the government
and these kinds of things are happening
here in reading how does that give
either the government or other Muslims
the confidence to give you money in
order to quote-unquote
D radicalize people and how is it d
radicalization when in fact people
become more more radical in their
attitude towards other Muslims it seems
to us that there has been a flaw in the
preventive strategy a real problem in
the way both prevent have reacted to
Muslim communities and as a result how
Muslim communities react to prevent so
this case this case of reading has
opened up many different windows of
inquiry and in this interview we've been
able to see
how things can go really wrong both for
those organizations who claim to claim
to be they say for example Salafi in
this case and for the government who
claim to be giving money or think that
they're giving money for the D
radicalization of Muslim people salam
alikum warahmatu I hear what I get